.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Peace.
(Frau)
Ich bete jeden Tag das Vaterunser.
Dort steht, dass man vergeben soll.
Das versuche ich.
Aber in gewissen
Situationen kann ich es nicht.
In gewissen Situationen
kommt die Wut wieder.
Es war seine Rasta-Mütze, die
Dominik Bein zum Verhängnis wurde.
Sieben Rechtsradikale
identifizierten den 15-jährigen
Schüler und Reggae-Fan
Dominik als Linken.
Deshalb
prügelten sie ihn beinahe tot.
Kein Einziger hat ihn angeschaut
und gesagt:
"Es tut mir so leid ..."
"Es tut mir so leid,
was ich dir angetan habe." Nein.
Dominik Bein
ist seit der Tat schwer behindert.
Ich muss
alles selber in die Hand nehmen.
Da fehlt jede Gerechtigkeit.
Haben die sich
bei Ihnen entschuldigt?- Nein.
Da gibt es keine Diskussion:
Einmal Opfer, immer Opfer.
* Er spricht unverständlich. *
Das Badezimmer.
Badezimmer.
Super, das WC.
Dominik Bein ist heute 34 Jahre alt.
Die Verletzungen an seinem Gehirn,
die ihm
die Skinheads zugefügt hatten,
waren irreversibel.
Noch ein Balkon?
* Er spricht unverständlich. *
Rauchen Sie dort?
- Ja.
Okay.
Bei unserer ersten Begegnung
zeigt er mir seinen grössten Stolz:
die eigene Wohnung.
Okay.
Sind Sie immer noch Reggea-Fan?
- Ja ...
Nicht mehr so stark?
- Nein.
Wohnt Dominik wirklich allein hier,
Frau Bein?- Ja.- Ja.
Ganz allein.
Das ist schon Luxus, oder?
Das ist ein Babyfon.
Damit überwache ich ihn.
Ah! Okay.
Also,
ganz allein kann er nicht wohnen.
Sie sind in der Nähe.
Ich bin schnell hier oben.
Ich höre alles.
Rosmarie Bein, Dominiks Mutter,
lebt im gleichen Haus,
zwei Etagen
unter ihrem erwachsenen Sohn.
Wenn Dominik Bein
einen epileptischen Anfall hat
oder seine wiederkehrenden Albträume
ihn plagen,
kann sie sofort zur Stelle sein.
Dominik Bein ist wegen
seiner schweren Hirnverletzungen
auf Betreuung angewiesen -
rund um die Uhr, ein Leben lang.
Fast 20 Jahre
sind seit der Tat vergangen.
Was willst du machen? Gurken?
Also, schäl die Gurken.
Er wurde schon selbstständiger.
Dazumal musste man
noch alles für ihn machen.
Auch Schuhe binden usw.
Das macht er heute alles selbst.
Es geht einfach alles sehr langsam.
Man kann ihm nicht mehrere Dinge
gleichzeitig sagen.
Er macht eines nach dem anderen.
Ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, er solle
das und das und das noch machen.
Man muss ihm
eine Aufgabe nach der anderen geben.
Aber dann macht er es sehr gut.
Ja, ein bisschen aufs T-Shirt.
Hast du sie schon angeschnitten?
Aber nicht dort.
Dafür brauchst du ein Brettchen.
Sprechen fällt Dominik Bein schwer.
Doch kognitiv ist er fit
und versteht alles um sich herum.
Auch seine eigene Situation.
Ja. Schön mit der linken Hand.
Weil er selbstbewusster wurde,
denkt er auch über sich selber nach.
Er merkt natürlich ...
Seine Freunde sind alle verheiratet
und haben Kinder.
Er merkt,
dass er immer an Grenzen stösst.
Das macht ihn fertig.
Damit kommt er fast nicht zurecht.
Er möchte auch eine Familie.
Er mag Kinder sehr gerne.
Das macht mich
auch immer sehr traurig.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
Es geschah im April 2003.
Mit einem Freund wollte Dominik Bein
ein Konzert in Frauenfeld besuchen.
Dieses war ausverkauft - die beiden
machten sich auf den Heimweg.
Und trafen
auf sieben rechtsextreme Schläger.
Diese waren angereist,
um "Linke zu vermöbeln".
Zwei Stunden hatten sie schon
vergeblich nach Opfern gesucht.
Dann trafen sie
auf Dominik und seinen Freund.
Dieser kam
mit einer Gehirnerschütterung davon.
Wahrscheinlich, weil er gleich nach
dem ersten Schlag bewusstlos wurde.
Dominik aber wollte fliehen:
Die sieben Skinheads
holten ihn zurück
und traktierten seinen Kopf
mit Stiefeltritten.
Du musst dich noch angurten,
Dominik.
Und du?
- Ja, ich auch.
Ja, das gilt auch für mich.
Auch fast 20 Jahre nach der Tat
braucht Dominik Bein
jeden Tag Therapien.
Tschüss, Domi.
Mach es gut. Pass gut auf.
Ja.
- Lern etwas.
Dass die Krankenkasse
die Therapien bezahlt,
musste Rosmarie Bein aufwendig
mit Dominiks Anwalt erstreiten.
Die Selbstbehalte aber
bleiben an Mutter und Sohn hängen.
Gut.
Eins.
Zwei.
- Gut.
Drei.
- Vier.
Spanien.
Nein.
Schw...
...eiz.
* Er macht Geräusche. *
Bei schweren Schädel-Hirn-Traumas
ist das Reden meist ein Teilaspekt,
der betroffen ist.
Aber es kommen noch viele andere
kognitive Funktionen hinzu:
Aufmerksamkeit,
Antrieb, Gedächtnis ...
Und allgemein auch
eine Verlangsamung, die man merkt.
Hinzu
kommen seine regelmässigen Blackouts,
in denen Dominik Bein
alles um sich herum vergisst.
Da kommt er. Hallo, Dominik.
Ich habe nicht gesehen,
wie du rauskamst.
Aber du hast uns gesehen.
Ging es gut in der Logopädie?
- Ja.
Was musstest du machen?
Wörter mit den Ballons sagen?
Städte oder Länder?- Ja.
Was ist das Schlimmste daran,
wenn man nicht reden kann?
Muss ich helfen?
Er kann keine Satzbildungen machen.
Er findet oft den Satz nicht,
den er sagen möchte.
Er weiss im Kopf,
was er sagen möchte,
kann ihn aber nicht sagen.
Das ist eine grosse Belastung.
Und wenn er mal ein bisschen reden
konnte, ist er danach sehr müde.
Danke.
Bitte. Schönen Nachmittag.
Ja.
- Danke.
Dominik Bein hat die Prügelattacke
der Neonazis nur ganz knapp überlebt.
Seine linke Körperhälfte war gelähmt.
Der 15-Jährige musste wieder gehen,
sprechen, sogar schlucken lernen.
Sein Berufswunsch, Rettungssanitäter
bei der Rega zu werden,
bleibt unverwirklicht.
Zukunftsträume -
mit gezielten Stiefeltritten
gegen seinen Kopf vernichtet.
Ich zeige Ihnen jetzt drei Bilder
und sage Ihnen einen Satz.
Und Sie sagen mir, zu welchem
der drei Bilder der Satz passt.
"Ich muss zum Zahnarzt."
Mhm. Warum passt das dazu?
Weil das eine Zahnbürste ist.
(Mann) Durch die Schläge
kam es zu einer
erheblichen Verletzung des Gehirns.
Ausserdem trat komplizierend
eine Blutung dazu,
die eine Operation notwendig machte.
Da wurde
nicht nur das Blut entfernt,
sondern es mussten Teile des Gehirns
reseziert werden.
Die Genugtuung für diese Tat
leistete anstelle der mittellosen
Täter der Kanton Thurgau.
Die Summe von 190'000 Fr.
investierten Mutter und Sohn
in eine Wohnung für Dominik.
Eines seiner täglichen Rituale:
Er dreht sich
einen Joint aus CBD-Hanf.
Warum rauchen Sie das?
- Das raucht man ...
Um zu relaxen?
- Damit du dich entspannen kannst.
Relaxen.
- Relaxen?- Ruhiger werden.
Ja, um richtig runterzufahren.
Genau.
Sie lassen ihn
wirklich viel allein machen.
Eigentlich alles.
Die Menschen fühlen sich nicht gut,
wenn man ihnen bei allem hilft.
Behinderte wollen nicht,
dass man bei allem hilft.
Sie wollen viel selber machen.
- Ja.
Sie bitten um Hilfe,
wenn sie etwas brauchen.
Ist das auch der Grund,
warum Sie ihn
nicht in ein Heim geben wollen?- Ja.
Dort
dürfen sie gar nichts selber machen.
"Das gibt noch mehr Arbeit."
"Wenn die selber einschenken
und danebengiessen,
müssen wir noch putzen."
Hier giesst er auch daneben.
Aber dann sage ich:
"Dort ist der Lumpen."
"Hol ihn und putz!"
Das bedeutet aber auch,
dass Sie immer schauen müssen.
Ja. Ich bin ja hier.
- Nein.
Ich nehme mein Tablett auch raus
und esse.
Er ist nicht einverstanden.
- Nein.
Er will nicht,
dass ich immer schaue.
Er will viel selber machen.
Manchmal sieht er dann,
dass etwas nicht funktioniert
und er das noch nicht selber kann.
Dann muss ich noch helfen.
Ich gehe runter.
Du weisst, wo ich bin.
Einfach reinkommen,
wenn du etwas brauchst.- Ja.
Okay. Tschüss.
Die Schuhe noch versorgen,
sonst fällt die Mutter drüber.
Auf substanzielle
Schadenersatzzahlungen der Täter
wartet Dominik Bein
bis heute vergeblich.
Er lebt mit gut 1'400 Fr. IV-Rente
pro Monat.
Für den Pflegeaufwand
und seinen Verdienstausfall
müssten ihm die Täter
mehrere Millionen Franken bezahlen.
Peace.
- Peace?
Schön, so zu leben,
Ihre Mutter unten und sie hier oben?
Nein.
Ist das nicht schön?
Was möchten Sie denn?
Allein.
- Allein leben, hm?- Ja.
Mindestens einer
von Dominiks Peinigern war Mitglied
der militanten Neonazi-Organisation
"Blood and Honour".
Einer der Täter
hatte sich in der Untersuchungshaft
das Leben genommen.
Das Obergericht des Kantons Thurgau
verurteilte
die sechs anderen Angeschuldigten
wegen versuchter vorsätzlicher Tötung
zu Zuchthausstrafen
von fünf bis sechseinhalb Jahren.
Alle sechs zogen das Urteil
ans Bundesgericht weiter,
das ihre Beschwerden abwies.
(Frau) Hier hinten
hatte es diese Sicherheitsschleusen,
durch die man musste.
Das war immer
ein Spiessrutenlauf ...
... um an diesen Jugendlichen
vorbeizugehen,
welche
die Angeschuldigten begleiteten.
Das war unangenehm.
Wegen
des riesigen Publikumsinteresses
wurden die Prozesse
in den Gemeindesaal
von Felben-Wellhausen verlegt.
Wir sassen hier vorne.
Also ich als Anwältin,
und die Verteidiger da drüben.
Und hier hinten war voll.
Ist diese Verhandlung,
dieser Prozess und dieser Vorfall
einzigartig in Ihrer Laufbahn?
Eine Gewalttat
ist nie gerechtfertigt.
Aber was unter dem Titel
dieser Gruppierung
"Blood and Honour" lief ...
Dass man einfach
wahllos jemanden aussucht,
nur weil er eine Mütze trägt,
die ihnen nicht passt,
und ihn zum Invaliden schlägt -
diese Brutalität
ist mir nie mehr begegnet.
Das waren ja mehrere.
Man machte das zusammen.
Das ist mir jetzt noch präsent.
Bernadette Zürcher
arbeitet nicht mehr als Anwältin.
Nicht nur, aber auch,
weil Opfer von Gewaltdelikten
so schlechte Karten haben.
Wir haben ein Rechtssystem,
das diesen Opfern
beschränkt finanzielle Mittel
zur Verfügung stellt.
Das fand ich immer etwas speziell:
Wenn ich
ein Strassenverkehrsopfer vertrete,
ist da die Haftpflichtversicherung -
dann ist der Schaden bezahlt.
Was ich hier stossend finde:
Bei so einem Fall,
wo man bewusst und willentlich
jemanden schädigt,
ihm in den Kopf tritt
und wirklich in Kauf nimmt,
dass eine bleibende Schädigung
entsteht,
wird das Opfer nicht entschädigt.
Was denken die Täter
heute über ihre Tat?
Bereuen sie den Gewaltexzess?
Die sechs Männer sind seit über
zehn Jahren wieder auf freiem Fuss.
Ich schreibe ihnen einen Brief
und bitte
um ein anonymisiertes Interview.
Dominik Beins Anwalt
wird meinen Brief
an die sechs Männer weiterleiten,
um an ihr Gewissen zu appellieren.
So, wie er immer wieder versucht,
sie
an ihre finanziellen Verpflichtungen
Dominik Bein gegenüber zu erinnern.
Mit geringem Erfolg:
In zehn Jahren flossen tröpfchenweise
rund 20'000 Fr. Schadenersatz.
Gefordert wären mindestens 3 Mio. Fr.
In einem oder zwei Fällen
riefen sie an und sagten,
ich solle endlich aufhören,
sie hätten ihre Strafe abgesessen
und mehr könnten sie nicht machen.
Das waren verschiedene Elemente.
Als ich die letzte Runde machte
und auch sagte,
das Fernsehen sei ebenfalls
an ihrem Standpunkt interessiert,
hörte ich von einem:
"Mein Anwalt meldet sich dann."
Scheinbar ist er in der Lage,
einen Anwalt zu finanzieren.
Aber er war nie in der Lage,
Dominik auch nur einen Franken
zukommen zu lassen,
um dessen Situation zu verbessern.
Es ist das Opferhilfegesetz
vor seiner Revision 2005,
das diesen Missstand möglich macht.
Genauer gesagt,
das sog. Quotenvorrecht des Kantons.
Denn anstelle der mittellosen Täter
bezahlte die Opferhilfe,
also der Kanton Thurgau,
die 190'000 Fr. Genugtuung
an Dominik Bein und seine Mutter.
Bevor er nun
Schadenersatz fordern kann,
müssen die Täter diese 190'000 Fr.
an den Kanton Thurgau zurückzahlen.
Der Staat blockiert die Forderung.
Nehmen wir an,
jemand hat nach Haftpflichtrecht
1 Mio. Fr. von einem Täter zugute -
was im Fall von Dominik Bein theo-
retisch problemlos möglich wäre -,
und der Staat hat irgendwo mal
100'000 Fr. bezahlt,
dann kann das Opfer
seinen Schadenersatzanspruch
so lange nicht geltend machen,
als dass der Staat seine 100'000 Fr.
nicht zurückerhalten hat.
Was mit den anderen 900'000 Fr. ist,
kümmert den Staat eigentlich nicht.
Und er
blockiert den Anspruch des Opfers,
wenn er ihn
gegen die Täter geltend machen will.
Das Departement für Justiz
und Sicherheit des Kantons Thurgau
sei daran, die geschuldete Summe
einzufordern, heisst es dort.
Wegen des laufenden Verfahrens
nimmt aber
niemand weiter Stellung zum Fall.
Mach sie mal auf.
Denkst du, es blubbert raus?
- Mhm.
Aha.
- Nein, nein. Nein.
Ja. Komm.
Hast du sie geschüttelt?
- Nein.- Oh!
Dominik Bein
lebt unter dem Existenzminimum.
Seine 73-jährige, geschiedene Mutter
unterstützt ihn mit ihrer AHV-Rente,
so gut es geht.
Und die Täter?
Das fand ich immer sehr ungerecht:
Sie kamen ins Gefängnis,
sassen ihre Strafe ab
und kriegten einen Bewährungshelfer.
Aber das Opfer kriegte niemanden.
Da kam niemand und sagte:
"Wir übernehmen das oder das."
Oder: "Darüber müssen Sie sich
keine Gedanken machen,
kümmern Sie sich um Dominik,
wir helfen Ihnen da schon."
Da kam niemand.
Da hat niemand geholfen.
Man muss selbst schauen,
wie man weiterkommt.
Ich mag es denen gönnen, dass sie
einen Bewährungshelfer haben
und wieder aufs rechte Gleis kommen.
Aber wenn Sie schon
auf das rechte Gleis kommen,
sollten sie auch das bezahlen,
was sie verschuldet haben.
Es ist einfach schwierig für ihn.
Er wäre auch lieber gesund.
Aber es ist jetzt halt so.
Das Schicksal
hat uns einfach getroffen.
Drei Nachmittage pro Woche
unterstützt IV-Assistentin
Ilaria Capano
Dominik Bein und seine Mutter.
Sie ermöglicht ihm alles,
was Rosmarie Bein
nicht mehr leisten kann.
Sport z.B.
oder Begegnungen mit Gleichaltrigen.
Der Herr: dein Pferd.
Wir gehen nach vorne.
Aber an einen anderen Ort. Komm mit.
Dominik Bein liebt Tiere.
Und für ein paar wenige Monate
wurde letztes Jahr sein Traum wahr:
Er durfte einmal pro Woche
als Hilfspferdewart arbeiten,
sich
nützlich und wertgeschätzt fühlen.
Doch das Glück
war von kurzer Dauer und scheiterte -
einmal mehr - am Geld.
Dominiks Rente
und die AHV seiner Mutter
reichten auf Dauer nicht aus,
um eine Begleitperson zu bezahlen,
die einschreiten könnte,
wenn Dominik einen
seiner epileptischen Anfälle hätte.
So bleibt ihm
nur die wöchentliche Reitstunde
bei seinem Reitlehrer Murat.
Was mögen Sie so an Pferden?
An den Pferden mag ich das Reiten.
Das Traben und das Galoppieren.
Das. Ja.
(Murat) Und am liebsten schnell,
oder?- Ja. Ja.
Eine berufliche Ausbildung
lehnte die IV übrigens ab,
weil diese
nicht wirtschaftlich genug wäre:
Dominik Bein
kann den Mindestleistungslohn
von 2.55 Fr. nicht erzielen.
Und jetzt halten.
Jetzt ist gut, oder?
Also, halte dich gut fest.
Wir traben an. Bleib sitzen. Flavia.
* Schnalzen *
Trab.
Sitzen bleiben. Und, Flavia, Galopp.
* Schnalzen *
Gut. Beine lang machen
und die Schultern zurück.
Gut.
Was wäre Ihr grösster Wunsch
für Dominik?
Ich wünsche mir für Dominik,
dass er noch unabhängiger
und selbstständiger wird,
weil er auch in Zukunft sicherlich
immer Hilfe benötigen wird.
Auch dass er sich vielleicht in
die Arbeitswelt integrieren könnte,
dass er mehr Kontakte pflegen
könnte, dass er Freunde fände.
Dass er einfach Menschen
um sich hat, die ihn gernhaben.
Denn was sein wird,
wenn Dominiks Mutter
ihn aus gesundheitlichen Gründen
einmal nicht mehr unterstützen kann,
daran wagt hier niemand zu denken.
Er war immer fröhlich.
Und eine Peace-Person.
Eine Peace-Person?
- Immer Friede, Freude, Eierkuchen.
Er mochte Frieden und war gerne
mit seinen Freunden unterwegs.
Er war
ein ganz normaler Jugendlicher.
Auch an diesem Abend:
Sie gingen zu dritt los,
einer kriegte noch ein Ticket
und konnte rein.
Die anderen zwei
kriegten halt keines mehr.
Sie wollten um ca. 21.30 Uhr
nach Hause gehen.
Dann haben die denen abgepasst
und sie zusammengeschlagen.
Das war nicht so vorgesehen.
Aber ja ... Manchmal
kommt es anders, als man denkt.
Ich habe die Bande so oft
an Konzerte gefahren und abgeholt.
Dieses eine Mal ging ich nicht mit
und dachte:
"Die schaffen das allein."
"Ich muss im Geschäft arbeiten."
Das habe ich mir schwer vorgeworfen,
dass ich mich einmal
nicht um sie gekümmert habe.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
Selbstvorwürfe
einer gepeinigten Mutter.
Und auch die Prozesse
waren ein traumatisches Erlebnis
für Rosmarie Bein.
Das hat mich
wahnsinnig lang belastet.
Die Aussagen und die ...
... Ausreden, die sie hatten.
Nein, das hat mich extrem belastet.
Kein einziger hat Dominik angeschaut
oder wäre zu ihm gekommen,
um zu sagen: "Es tut mir leid ..."
"Es tut mir so leid,
was ich dir angetan habe." Nein.
Nein. Das ist ihnen völlig egal.
Völlig egal,
ob sie einen Menschen halb töten.
Die haben ihn fast getötet.
Er kann nicht so leben
wie ein freier Mensch.
Regelmässige Schadenersatzzahlungen
der Täter
würden Dominik Bein
immerhin etwas Freiheit geben.
Es ist traurig,
dass sie nicht einsehen,
dass sie für ihn sorgen müssten.
Sie haben das verursacht.
Sie haben
Dominiks Leben kaputtgemacht.
Er sagte oft, er wäre lieber tot,
als so zu leben.
Aber mittlerweile
lebt er schon gerne.
Wenn er sich mal
eine Freude leisten kann.
Aber wenn ich immer sagen muss, dass
wir uns das nicht leisten können,
dass wir sparen müssten
und das nicht gehe ...
... fragt er sich,
wofür er überhaupt da sei.
Er kann nicht arbeiten.
Er würde gerne, kann aber nicht.
Ich möchte eigentlich schon lange
nichts mehr von den Typen wissen.
Man überlegt nur immer,
wie ein Mensch so sein kann.
Wie können Menschen so sein?
Das belastet einen.
Eigentlich habe ich
die Kraft dafür nicht mehr.
Aber Dominik zuliebe ...
Er sagt jeweils: "Nein, Mami,
die müssen doch für mich aufkommen."
"Ich kann ja nichts.
Ich würde, wenn ich könnte."
Ja.
Er kann nicht.
Über zehn Jahre
hatten die Täter nun Gelegenheit,
sich gütlich
mit Dominik Bein zu einigen
und freiwillig
Schadenersatz zu zahlen.
Jetzt kommt der Zivilprozess.
Die Anzeichen im Hintergrund
sind bei den meisten Tätern so -
soweit wir Anzeichen haben -,
dass wir vermuten müssen,
dass der Zivilprozess zwar schön ist
und wir ohnehin gewinnen,
aber nicht ernsthaft
Geld bekommen werden.
Es geht am Schluss
nicht um die Frage,
ob der Prozess gut ist
und wir ihn gewinnen, sondern:
"Wann kriegt Dominik endlich Geld?"
Nicht, weil er geldsüchtig ist,
sondern damit er
ein normales, menschenwürdiges Leben
führen könnte.
Das ist das Thema.
Wir werden jetzt demnächst
gegen zwei oder drei dieser Täter
mit Zivilklagen loslegen.
Damit die Ernsthaftigkeit
auch wirklich untermauert wird.
Ich glaube,
dass jeder vernünftige Mensch,
wenn er unterdessen
wirklich wieder integriert ist,
langsam erkennen müsste,
dass er in einer sehr viel besseren
Situation ist als das Opfer.
Haben Sie zwei Handys?
- Mhm.
Dominik kann nicht gut reden.
Doch als er eine Packliste für
seine Ferien erstellt, bemerke ich,
dass ihm Schreiben leichter fällt.
Eine neue Art
der Kommunikation zwischen uns.
Dominik, Sie können so gut schreiben.
- Ja.
Darf ich etwas fragen?
Was würden Sie von den Tätern er-
warten, die Sie so zugerichtet haben?
Mhm.
"Von den Tätern
erwarte ich eigentlich,
dass sie mir einen zünftigen
Lohnersatz bezahlen müssen."
Mhm.
Haben sie sich mal
bei Ihnen entschuldigt?
Nein.
Nein. Nein. Nein.
Möchten Sie, dass die Täter das tun?
Dass sie sich
bei Ihnen entschuldigen?
Hm!
Nein.
- Nein?
Möchten Sie nichts mehr
mit ihnen zu tun haben?- Ja.
Rosmarie Bein
ist gesundheitlich angeschlagen.
Trotzdem ist sie
rund um die Uhr für ihren Sohn da.
Nur um 18 Uhr
ist ihre heilige Serienstunde,
ihr täglicher Ausflug
in eine heile Welt.
Woher nehmen Sie die Energie?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Ich mache es einfach.
Im Spital
sagte mir eine junge Ärztin:
"Frau Bein, leben Sie Ihr Leben."
"Sie können nicht das
von Dominik leben."
Da sagte ich:
"Würde ich ihn irgendwo versorgen,
könnte ich mir nicht mehr
ins Gesicht schauen."
Ich könnte mich
nicht mehr im Spiegel ansehen.
Ich würde denken,
als Mutter versagt zu haben.
Ich mache das
ja auch gerne für Dominik.
Ich mache das wirklich gerne.
Obwohl es manchmal Stress ist.
Wann?
Wenn es ihm nicht gut geht
und ich nicht helfen kann,
oder wenn er ausrastet,
weil etwas nicht geht.
Er merkt auch,
wenn er an Grenzen stösst.
Wenn er etwas nicht bewältigen kann.
Dann hat er seine Ausraster.
Er kann nicht Autofahren.
Er kann keine Familie haben.
Er hat keine Freunde mehr.
Er hat keine Freundin.
Das plagt ihn auch.
Er hätte gerne eine.
Lange
suchte er eine im Internet.
Aber das ging irgendwie nicht.
Ja.
All das, was junge Menschen
halt gerne möchten.
Er möchte gerne an ein Konzert
oder weggehen ...
Eine sinnlose Gewalttat,
sechs uneinsichtige Täter,
zwei zerstörte Leben -
Dominik Bein und seine Mutter,
lebenslänglich Opfer.
Oh!
Er hat wieder gewonnen.
Wenn eine gute Fee käme und Ihnen
drei Wünsche erfüllen würde ...
... was würden Sie sich wünschen?
Ja, dann ...
Und gut sprechen können.
Das ist doch das Wichtigste.
Dass du gut sprechen kannst.
* Er spricht unverständlich. *
Gut, noch mal. Komm, weiter.
- Ja.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022